match bien triste match nul 0 à 0 il y a
eu tout sauf un vrai match de foot si ça
continue comme ça l'équipe de France va
aller droit dans un mur à la Coupe du
monde cet été
pour que tu aies une prime particulière
pour suivre ses purges de foot féminin
alors
qui veut agir
ça fait du bien d'entendre quelqu'un par
les librement dans les médias et ensuite
pardon le foot féminin c'est chiant
comme la pluie qui a envie de regarder
un match Montpellier Guingamp de foot
féminin personne moi j'aime bien non
mais alors bizarrement ça fait de très
bonnes audiences à la télé mais moi je
regarde où donne beau le foot féminin
ça fait très bonne audiences mais pardon
mais c'est extrêmement chiant à regarder
et il a raison ça fait du bien
d'entendre des gens qui donnent leur
avenir un peu librement
cette misogynie se sexisme France
Norvège bien sûr elles ont gagné le
tournoi elles sont formidables et
j'espère qu'elles seront un championne
et elles vous feront fermer votre clapet
et franchement
et celui-là
c'est on tourne à droite mais
féminins mais dire que c'est une purge
et qu'il faut payer les journalistes en
plus qui suivent ça c'est un méchants
l'essor du football passera par les
femmes voilà si quelqu'un doit
renouveler le football ce seront les
femmes c'est merveilleuse
non mais Gilles en chemin tu as perdu
ton second degré donc j'imagine parce
que c'est quand même une vanne il a
perdu ses couilles aussi
[Rires]
j'étais sur le rocher là voilà tu vois
bon ben voilà oui moi j'y connais rien
football mais Daniel Riolo en revanche
je le connais je sais qu'il aime qu'il
aime les femmes avec un grand F
s'accompagne est une est une amie c'est
ma meilleure amie voilà donc vous allez
en dire
et sa compagne à faire un documentaire
sublime sur l'équipe de France féminine
et que il connaît toutes les choses et
voilà et c'est vraiment là parce qu'il
avait envie de faire un petit pied de
nez un truc de vanne n'est pas à prendre
au sens littéral sur les sur les matchs
en Belgique et là tu devrais t'offusquer
c'est qu'on mette ce match là France
Norvège face à la Ligue des Champions
là on se fout de la gueule des choses
parce que évidemment on va pas les
regarder parce qu'on va préférer
regarder Liverpool real alors là là je
t'entends pas en revanche ça fait une
bonne audience
ça fait Joséphine au moins quand
joséphine Ange
quand j'ai vu la programmation je me
suis dit c'est pas un cadeau pour les
filles donc c'est ça les a sauvé comme
ça personne n'a regardé
je viens tout entendre mais je vais pas
faire 800 km tout les semaines pour
entendre des conneries comme ce que
raconte
1600 km
un spécialiste du foot en plus
mais c'est pas de la faute des filles
elle progresse je suis entièrement
d'accord c'est de plus en plus plaisant
mais l'écart entre le foot féminin et le
match qu'on a regardé Liverpool et le
Real c'est tellement stratosphérique
elle n'attendront jamais ce niveau
est-ce que le football c'est un sport
physique tous les sports sont finis mal
mais c'est honteux ce que tu dis
d'accord c'est un peu d'accord bien sûr
donc pas pour les femmes
excuse-toi avant avant que la polémique
jamais je m'excuserai
tu crois que le foot tu es pas un sport
physique t'as jamais regardé à ma
question
de plus en plus
bien sûr mais sauf que la différence
tellement grand que la match de foot
actuellement
vous avez jamais rien du tout féminin je
regarde très souvent elle sait que je
regarde souvent quand vous regardez un
match de foot en trois passes ils sont
ils passent
après ce qui vient de dire là tu feras
plus jamais l'aller-retour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et il arrive
en plus pendant 48 minutes tu parles
tout seul
alors premièrement je suis très fier de
regarder Dumbo deuxièmement deuxièmement
je suis d'accord avec Gilles encore une
fois mais c'est exceptionnel mais là je
suis d'accord avec toi est-ce que pour
moi le foot féminin c'est effectivement
l'avenir il y a vraiment une énergie là
de l'équipe de France de féminin qui ont
joué smartphone
[Rires]
il y a eu combien de spectateurs dans le
stade mais 100000 non non
il y avait Baltimore il y avait les deux
cascarinos il y avait il y avait Wendy
renard bah voilà non
j'adore
c'est pour le dos Géraldine tais-toi un
peu
[Applaudissements]
on est agressé parce qu'on aime les
femmes ici vous vous rendez compte je
dois me défendre d'aimer le foot féminin
pendant des mois et des mois s'il vous
plaît je peux demander à ma meuf ce que
l'on pense c'est qui Daniel
honnêtement j'en pense rien mais j'adore
la façon dont Géraldine défense en homme
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
excusez-moi le débat il est pas sur le
foot féminin une prime pour suivre les
purges on aurait dit exactement la même
chose pour un match entre Marseille et
Saint-Étienne j'ai trouvé ça alors moi
j'adore ces deux équipes j'adore les
enfants Saint-Étienne stéphanoise
chaudron
vert c'est comme ça que j'appelle Daniel
ce serait concilier avec l'humour et le
second degré effectivement
sur le physique des femmes donc reprend
toi la polémique la polémique est en
train de percevoir je parle physique et
ne peuvent pas faire en athlétisme elles
sont merveilleuses elles sont tous les
sports
et dans quel sport
le sport
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la devise des jeux c'est quoi plus vite
plus vite plus vite plus haut
[Applaudissements]
plus fort il y a pas une femme qui va
plus vite qu'un noir
c'est pas la devise c'est pas de ma
faute c'est le sport c'est quelque chose
de fille une activité physique
exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la
polémique Jean-Michel je suis ahuri
ahuri franchement
3 millions qui vont l'entendre dire que
les femmes ne peuvent pas faire de sport
c'est ça
que tu as dit ça et tu te reprends pas
ça continue tu persistes tu es dans la
Bible tombe dans la Bible